While I was an executive and
CEO of large companies.
And what I found is that the investment,
the work with entrepreneurs has
kept me alive, kept me excited.
And so when I left the old role,
I decided that that's what I want to
do full time and
that's what I've been doing ever since.
A year ago, in attempts to basically
somehow institutionalize my work with
startups, I've set up in an Exeter here
in the Silicon Valley with two partners,
James Corden and Stan Chenovsky, two
good friends of mine that are very very
successful entrepreneurs and investors.
And we're now helping young
teams from Israel and
from the United States basically
accelerate their business
around network effect businesses,
so that's what we focus on.